i want to turn to the hunter biden
situation and we're just getting more
breaking news and it's happening just
before this show
started telling our own brook
singman that two sources familiar with
the investigation
tell fox news the investigation being
run out of the u.s attorney's office in
delaware
into hunter biden's uh quote tax affairs
includes looking at that laptop
purportedly belonging to hunter biden
fox news first reported in october
that the fbi subpoenaed a laptop and
hard drive reportedly belonged to hunter
biden in connection with a money
laundering investigation
in late 2019. one document obtained by
fox
was a subpoena sent to the owner of the
laptop repair shop
to testify before u.s district court
december 9th 2019
uh goes on to say we we first reported
that the fbi was in possession of that
laptop
so we're not only seeing here jason tax
investigation
a grand jury tied to a target subject of
hunter biden
but also now that the laptop is part of
this and that it was
now overt not just a covert part of the
fbi investigation
right and of course there are a lot of
news organizations
that didn't want to look at any of this
prior to the election
they thought it might help donald trump
in the election if they did that so they
they avoided the story and you know i
can understand trump supporters
looking at this and and and being
infuriated by it
uh perhaps there's something there uh
with regard to hunter's
business dealings in the ukraine or in
in china
uh we don't know yet but we do know that
there's a
very clear double standard here when it
comes to looking
at these matters depending on which
party you're a member of when it comes
to the press's
attention so we don't know if it would
have affected the election but i can
understand why a lot of trump supporters
right now are
are furious that this is only being
looked into at this point
you know jonathan quickly the we saw in
the durham case that the
the attorney general putting a special
prosecutor label
uh just to protect perhaps what's going
to continue in that investigation
this one potentially he could do the
same thing as you're getting ready for
january 20th
well this will be the the first test of
of what joe biden has
said he will do with his justice
department joe biden has pledged that he
will keep his justice department at
arm's length that he will not
intervene well it doesn't get much more
of a an
ultimate test than your own son being
investigated
by federal law enforcement for
business dealings with china and tax
affairs so how joe biden handles that
investigation will be
a really crucial test of how he's going
to operate with his justice department
okay uh all of this breaking just before
the show we're digesting it all we'll
bring it to you
as we get more details panel we'll see a
little bit later in the show